-Nice to see you.
It's so cool to be
in this building, man.
I have to say, this is, like,
a big deal for me.
I'm a big "SNL" junkie.
-Fantastic.
Well, this is the place to be.
-I have to ask you a question.
-Go for it.
-So, Will Ferrell was hosting
this weekend, as you know.
-Yes.
-So I was reminded of a sketch
that for "SNL" fans
is sort of hallowed ground
for just, like,
the best stupid sketch
of all-time.
I recently watched it,
and I realized, oh, my God,
a young Seth Meyers
is right in the front row,
and I want to know
if you have the same affection
for Gus Chiggins
and the old prospector.
-Old prospector, yeah.
-As I do, and many other people.
-Yes.
-I just to know
what that was like.
-Well, it was -- I tell you,
because they just put it
on YouTube.
It was my third week
at the show.
-That's amazing.
-And it was a really emotional
week at the show
because someone had sent anthrax
to the building.
So everybody -- It was like
right af-- it was 2001.
So it was a crazy time.
And it was so --
That sketch was so dumb.
-So it nose-dives down
the rabbit hole really easy.
-And Will makes choices
that no other performer --
and he does that all the time --
but he makes --
he takes so many pauses.
-Oh, you could see, all of you
guys are like, what is going on?
-Yeah, I had this moment of
"Oh, my God, if I laugh,
they're going to fire me,"
and then I look around at, like,
Jimmy Fallon, and Horatio.
I'm like, "Well, they're still
here, so I'm fine."
-But in that moment, do you know
that it's, like,
this is something people
are going to like
or are you like, "Oh, my God."
-The crazy thing was it got cut.
It was only at dress,
so that was the thing is
I thought, "Oh, this is
the greatest thing
that ever happened."
And then I thought, "Oh, great
things get cut all the time.
I'm just new here."
And then they really don't.
-That was it. That was the one.
-Most things that get cut
are like,
"Yeah, that was the right thing
to get cut."
-If you don't know it, go check
out the old prospector.
-Old prospector, now available
on YouTube.
-Delightfully stupid.
It's amazing.
-We, actually -- So, we ran
into each other backstage
at the Golden Globes.
-Yeah.
You did a great job by the way.
-Thank you very much.
But I was --
[ Cheers and applause ]
We had -- Thank you.
We had an after party,
and someone told me
you were on your way.
I left because
my wife was pregnant.
But you did make it in,
but it was not easy.
-Oh I could not get into your
party, no, no, they don't.
-But you were on the list.
-Yeah, that's what they tell me.
It would have been nice
at the time.
No, we got in eventually.
In fact my fiancée and I,
we took a guy that we met --
we thought we were being nice,
being like,
"Dude, we're on the list.
We'll take you to the party."
He's like, "Okay,
let me get the Uber."
So we're, like, riding high,
like, "We'll show this guy
a good time.
We're Hollywood folks."
And we get there
and they're like, "No."
[ Laughter ]
And then go figure,
this guy goes,
"Hey, I know that guy,"
and he walked us in.
-Oh, really?
-Always takes the guy you think
isn't allowed at the party.
-Did you give him money
for the Uber I hope?
-No, no, I took that free ride.
[ Laughter ]
-So, we were talking backstage.
First two episodes of the show
is fantastic.
You play not a serial killer,
I guess. What --
-I guess the terminology
is spree killer.
I'm not
a licensed criminologist,
but it's a little different.
-Andrew Cunanan,
who killed Gianni Versace
and four other men
in the course of a very --
What is it like getting in
the head of someone like that?
Are you the kind of actor
who does that,
or are you just kind of --
-Yes and no.
I mean, look, I'm an actor.
So you obviously have to act
the part, so to speak,
but as far as putting your head
in that space,
I think people tend to forget
that people's lives
are much greater than the worst
things they've ever done.
And while obviously what he did
is deplorable and horrible
and still has echoes of tragedy
20 years later, I --
This is a bizarre comparison.
But if you -- like if I met you
at a bar on a bad night for you.
-Yeah.
-And then I told all my friends,
Seth Meyers is a jerk.
Even though that's really just
one night of your life.
-I think the most I ever killed
in one night was three.
-Was three, and that's like,
who's counting?
-Yeah, yeah.
-That's a bizarre comparison.
What I'm saying is
we all have --
you have to kind of count
the primary colors
between you and another person.
I don't approach it as,
"Oh, this guy killed people."
-Well, you also play him
because he was --
I mean, a liar, fabulous about
his own life to some degree.
But you have to bring a lot of
charm and charisma
to this character who obviously
we are seeing --
we're kind of
zoned into this awful time.
-Yeah, he was a famously likable
guy most early in his life.
When I was saying we don't know
somebody from the worst things
ever done.
I met so many people that met
him throughout his life
that really were
quite fond of him,
and he was famously affable.
Somebody came up to me.
I was in Vegas.
I was at a concert.
This guy comes up to me, he was
like, "You have to meet my wife.
She went to high school
with Andrew."
And she came up to me,
and she's talking about,
like, a teenage --
like a 15, 16-year-old kid.
She's like, "I just want to let
you know that when I met Andrew,
he was such a good friend to me.
He was somebody you could count
on, and I was heartbroken."
And that's when you go, "Okay,
we're not playing --
We're playing a person who has
gone down this destructive path,
and how does something so
promising
become something so horrible?"
That's kind of where --
-Well, you do a fantastic job
with it.
I can't wait to see the rest of
it because I --
you know, it's not one of those
shows where you tune in,
and you're like,
"Oh, that's a psycho killer."
You do a great job of bringing
a lot of the layers to it.
And thank you so much
for being here.
-Thank you for having me.
This is so cool.
-I'm so glad you didn't have
trouble at the door tonight.
-Yeah, and they let me
in this time.
-Darren Criss, everybody.